mesdames et messieurs bonsoir on
attendait du nouveau dans la sphère de
la séquestration de la saveur de france
un salvateur
à vrai dire il n'y en a pas et une
troisième journée l'épreuve a commencé
pour les otages dont cinq diplomates
français
le négociateur du quai d'orsay monsieur
cuvillier arrivé à salva derrière
poursuit ses contacts mais dans une
affaire comme celle-ci il faut
comprendre que la discrétion puisse être
un grand atout pour la réussite des
éventuelles négociations avec le bloc
populaire révolutionnaire vers 19h
cependant à paris des membres de ce bloc
populaire révolutionnaire ont téléphoné
à la fp visant deux choses primo
l'organisme d'un mouvement marxiste
deuxièmement leurs camarades de san
salvador n'iront jamais jusqu'à tuer
l'ambassadeur en tout cas une affaire
bien juste refuge en france le week-end
qui se termine aura été très important
sur le plan de la politique européenne
il y a eu le forum de radio monte carlo
dans la vie tu étais le président de la
république et sur lequel nous
reviendrons un peu plus tard dans ce
journal
il y a eu le discours à strasbourg de
monsieur chaban delmas qui a relancé
l'idée de la nouvelle société
mais cette fois ci à l'échelle
européenne en notant au passage la
continuité des efforts accomplis en
france depuis 20 ans en faveur de
l'édification de l'europe
ce sera d'ailleurs la seule intervention
du président de l'assemblée nationale
dans la campagne électorale européenne
il y a eu cette grande émission
conjointe d'antenne 2 et d'europe numéro
1 que la presse a commenté dans les
détails en en soulignant le grand succès
et qui avait été vu et entendu par au
moins 20 millions de téléspectateurs et
d'auditeurs
elle a constitué cette émission un coup
d'envoi du débat public entre les quatre
principales tendances françaises
elle a été un premier effort de
clarification à grande échelle pour que
nous comprenions mieux ce qu'est la
construction de l'europe et aussi ce
qu'est l'évolution de la scène politique
française en fonction de l'europe
pendant le débat la vente hier les
personnalités présentes ont mentionné à
diverses reprises monsieur pierre mauroy
l'un des leaders du parti socialiste il
est est ce soir l'invité du club de la
presse en europe nous verrons un débat
qu'a suivi pour nouvelle copains et
monsieur me roy a surtout parlé de leur
est acquis c'est vrai c'est vrai que le
crs a eu
des positions ce qui concerne le rap qui
était originale pour le moins et que je
ne partageais pas c'est une des raisons
pour lesquelles des guerres dans le
débat que nous avons eues avant metz
je pensais que effectivement il n'était
pas si simple de faire une synthèse avec
le crs il en a changé
il peut en changer c'est ce qu'il a dit
je n'en sais rien il faut les
questionner en tous les cas j'imagine
que sur ce plan là il ya eu une
évolution
le crs est en majorité du parti le parti
à une politique cette politique c'est
celle qui nous engage que l'on soit au
stress ou que l'on soit dans toutes
autres courants du parti socialiste
là est l'essentiel oui aller à
l'essentiel et surtout clarifier je
crois que c'était l'intention et la
volonté de monsieur pierre mauroy tout
au cours de cette émission qui va
s'achever maintenant dans quelques
instants après le grand débat de
vendredi soir sur europe 1 et antenne 2
on s'interrogeait tous les observateurs
s'interrogent s'interrogeaient sur de
nouvelles convergences politiques
possibles
eh bien je crois qu'au cours de cette
émission d'europe 1 ce soir on était
très impressionné par les similitudes au
moins certains moments de langage entre
monsieur pierre mauroy et le président
de la république dans cette émission de
forums de mlc dont léon zitrone parlais
tout à l'heure
monsieur pierre mauroy lui aussi estime
qu'il n'y a plus de leur raison de
parler de querelles de la
supranationalité et il estime aussi que
personne ne remet en cause l'application
du traité de rome pour monsieur pierre
mauroy il s'agit donc de clarifier leurs
déhanchés la politique intérieure et les
élections européennes même si dit il il
ya des interférences ils constatent à la
suite du débat de vendredi soir que sur
les quatre listes il y en a deux qui
déclare forfait de qui n'ont pas de
politique européenne et deux autres et
qui ont une politique européenne
c'est-à-dire l'udf et le parti
socialiste même si ces politiques sont
contradictoires et monsieur mauroy bien
sûr insiste sur ses contradictions une
critique vivement la politique de
monsieur bart il reproche madame simone
veil de présenter leur offre comme étant
une caserne d'ali baba dans laquelle on
va trouver tous les miracles toutes les
solutions durables aux problèmes qui se
posent en france
et il estime qu'il doit y avoir entre la
gauche et la droite la même opposition
sur le plan de l europe que sur le plan
de la france mais ce qui restera je
crois quand même de cette émission des
déclarations de venir me voir
c'est cet effort de clarification et
c'est aussi le fait on peut le dire je
crois que entre le président de la
république d'une part le gouvernement et
la liste de madame simone veil et
d'autres bars le parti socialiste il y à
un accord au moins un accord sur la
façon de poser les problèmes sur la
façon de fixer le cadre dans lequel les
problèmes doivent se poser s'il ya
toujours bien entendu un désaccord sur
les solutions à apporter à ce problème à
rtl aujourd'hui monsieur jean françois
poncet notre ministre des affaires
étrangères a dit l'économie française
telle qu'elle existe ne peut pas se
concevoir en dehors du marché commun les
difficultés de l'europe est bien le
marché commun les à atténuer et à morte
à l'heure où le débat européen prend de
plus en plus ample air demain un nouveau
point fort politique sur une trentaine
en direct à 20h30 monsieur raymond barre
premier ministre se trouvera face un
journaliste allemand un journaliste
britannique un journaliste italien dans
une émission spéciale que mènera jean
pierre elkabbach je vous rappelle pierre
monsieur bart parlante à saint maur a
souligné qu'il ne laisserai jamais dire
que le gouvernement qu'il préside est un
gouvernement qui consent à l'abaissement
de la france demain dont à 20h30 puis
vendredi 11 mai notre journal antenne de
midi sera consacré au 23ème congrès du
parti communiste qui aura lieu à saint
point près le paris deux émissions qui
s'annonce particulièrement intéressante
de suite mais je reviens au forum de
radio monte carlo au camel copain vient
de faire allusion le président de la
république et à répéter tout l'intérêt
du plan de développement du sud ouest un
plan adopté il ya quelques semaines par
un conseil des ministres
l'un des atouts majeurs de cette très
belle région qu'est le sud ouest est
certainement informatique
lisons des structures déjà existantes en
informatique un atout qui comme le
montre le reportage de philippe dumez de
jean vila doit être encore plus
largement utilisée si la crainte des
allemandes qui au début du siècle fit
installer les usines héros nautique à
bordeaux et à toulouse
depuis elles se sont développées avec
plus ou moins de succès suivant les
programmes
on peut citer les hélicoptères qui se
vendent bien
l'airbus qui démarre doucement et la
série des falcons qui est un succès la
construction des avions a entraîné
l'implantation dans le sud-ouest
d'autres industries en particulier
électroniques et informatiques
la présence d'ouvriers qualifiés dans la
région a certainement tenter les
industriels français ou étrangers
malheureusement dans cette industrie de
pointe que sont les ordinateurs il faut
savoir faire des circuits intégrés et
des composants or dans ce domaine les
américains enfin quasi monopole alors on
peut se demander si une société comme
ibm installé à bordeaux et à montpellier
ne considère pas cette région comme un
pays sous-développé coupe et je souhaite
à tous les pays en voie de développement
d'être capable d'avoir la chance de
fabriquer des ordinateurs comme celui ci
un des plus récents et les plus modernes
qui se produit actuellement dans le
monde tout est cette usine emploie 2200
personnes toutes françaises et l'export
85% de sa production dans plus de 100
pays
les salaires sont salaires et charges
plus élevées ici que dans les usines ibm
votée aux états unis non vraiment je
crois que si ibm produits en france
c'est parce que ibm a pour principe de
produire là où il ya un marché
après plusieurs années le bilan des
différentes industries d'électronique et
d'informatique est plutôt positif la
région et ses élus ont d'ailleurs su
trouver les bons arguments pour que les
industriels viennent chez eux
nous avons l'espace nous avons les
hommes nous avons surtout l'université à
bordeaux à toulouse et à montpellier à
toulouse plus de 2000 chercheurs
travaillent dans l'université et je
pense que c'est
cet environnement particulièrement
favorable incitera au développement et à
la création d'entreprises nouvelles on
peut effectivement constaté que les
relations industrielles université ou
école d'ingénieurs sont très bonnes dans
cette région elles sont sûrement un
élément positif pour le développement
des recherches dans une industrie de
pointe et les américains comme ibm ou
motorola et les français comme thomson
csf ne s'y sont pas trompés pour ces
grosses sociétés dont les sièges sont à
paris la décentralisation ne pose pas
trop de problème par contre pour un
jeune industriel qui vient de créer une
petite société d'électronique
l'isolément par rapport à paris est
presque un drame
sa société pourtant leader dans le monde
pour les jeux de télévision mais
l'administration est un boulet pour les
créateurs d'entreprise
l'administration est extrêmement pesante
pour les petites entreprises
la quantité de paperasse qu'il faut
faire pour démarrer une entreprise est
colossal et est extrêmement avare de ces
aides
on en parle beaucoup mais quand il
s'agit de débloquer les deniers et de
les donner aux entrepreneurs
il vaut mieux pas retenir sa respiration
au niveau du développement ça vous pose
des problèmes au niveau du développement
nous sommes dans une industrie
particulière l'industrie du jeu vidéo
l'industrie du micro ordinateur et une
industrie en plein boom
donc le problème que nous avons est
celui de faire face un développement
extrêmement rapide et c'est absolument
nécessaire autrement nous perdons pied
dans le créneau que nous visons donc se
développer rapidement en france à
l'heure actuelle ça n'est pas possible
un développement à 20% par an oui je
pense que c'est possible
sans vouloir éluder les problèmes
il est certain que les dernières
directives du gouvernement pour
l'aménagement du territoire devrait
apporter des solutions aux créateurs
d'entreprise
ce qui m'a le plus surpris pendant ce
reportage c'est la capacité de nos
ingénieurs à s'intégrer facilement dans
toutes les industries en pointe en
électronique en particulier regardez ce
n'est pas une salle de chirurgie c'est
un atelier de fabrication des plus
sophistiqués des circuits intégrés comme
il n'en existe qu'un ou deux dans le
monde cet atelier se trouve à toulouse
aux usines motorola est le grand
spécialiste est un français
ici on travaille à l'échelle de l'atome
l'avenir de l'électronique et de
l'informatique dans le sud ouest est
certainement prometteur mais les emplois
qui sont ou seront créés ne seront
jamais très important ce qui est sûr
c'est que cette région ne dépendra plus
uniquement que de l'industrie
aéronautique et la diversité dans ce
domaine est une bonne chose
étrange et en autriche les socialistes
de monsieur crise qui sont les gagnants
des élections ils auront dans le nouveau
parlement
quelque chose comme 18 députés de plus
que leurs adversaires démocrates
chrétiens nous vous entretenez trop
souvent hélas des conflits armés qui
surgissent de par le monde
or depuis plus d'un an se déroule une
guerre dont on n'a pas beaucoup parlé
pourtant aller dans un sens symbolique
elle met aux prises l'armée régulière de
l'afghanistan et les rebelles
ashton vous savez que depuis avril 78
l'afghanistan un régime prosoviétique on
dit en général kili à 5000 conseillers
soviétiques dans son armée les pachtouns
eux sont profondément empreint de leurs
traditions religieuses islamiques
voici un reportage exclusif réalisé pour
antenne de par notre confrère françois
mille scène du journal le méridien
guérilleros passe d'une vallée à l'autre
par des nids d'aigles du cunard du
nouristan et de l'hindou kouch
nous sommes à plus de 3000 mètres et
chaque jour les mic de l'armée afghane
des milk que l'on suppose pilotés par
des soldats soviétiques larguer leurs
bombes
c'est ensuite le tour des hélicoptères
qui attaquent les nids d'aigles au canon
par ses repères à deux jours de marche à
pied de la frontière pakistanaise
ils sont pratiquement hors d'atteinte
des troupes régulières afghanes
et puis pas même les mig ne pourrait les
priver de la prière
c'est un cérémonial quotidien cinq fois
par jour les pages tout se prosternent
vers l'est
moment important dans la journée du
rebelle symbolique aussi la prière à la
c'est la réponse à ce régime de kaboul
un régime prosoviétique donc hâté donc
sacrilège
l'islam est le fer de lance de cette
guérilla contre taraki et ses
conseillers soviétiques
ce sont eux qui sont assiégés dans ses
posts où toutes les pistes d'accès ont
été minés à portée de fusil des pages
tous dans leur caverne avec leur
armement hétéroclite des vieux fusil au
mieux des kalachnikovs récupérés sur des
déserteurs de tara qui il se cache tout
autour de ces cavernes et lance à partir
de là des escarmouches entre armes
l'appel quotidien lancé au porte-voix
pour inciter les soldats de tara qui à
venir les rejoignent
la voix porte loin voici ce qu'elle dit
nous sommes musulmans
nous ne devons pas nous entretuer
mettons ces étrangers à thé à la porte
de notre pays
en réponse quelques secondes plus tard
c'est la volée d'obus
un déluge de feu et d'acier sur les
pachtouns pour combattre les guérilleros
utilisent des méthodes plus que sommaire
qu'elle la fabrication de ces mines des
pins de tnt enveloppé dans du papier
journal avec un bout de ficelle tout
autour je parle évidemment redoutable
c'est à dire la guérilla c'est à dire
qu'il faut aller les déloger ces
rebelles pages tous dans leurs montagnes
et si jamais les soviétiques s'y
aventurer qui sait ce serait pour ces
soviétique la vietnam votre avis en
réalité et quel est l'enjeu de cette
guerre de cette rébellion dans le jeu
d'abord c'est pour les pachtouns
retrouver leur pays c'est à dire un pays
qui ne soit pas marxiste pro soviétique
et ensuite je trouve c'est un atout pour
l'occident c'est à dire que
l'afghanistan est aujourd'hui le dernier
verrou pour qu'il puisse empêcher les
soviétiques à se rendre sur golfe
persique des codes classiques
c'est-à-dire la route du pétrole c'est à
dire l'approvisionnement en pétrole pour
l'occident en fait ici on nous
reviendrons dans cette région du monde
mais cette fois pour vous présenter une
légende née à samarcande ou turquie en
iran où l'on a noté plusieurs nouvelles
exécutions l'on annonce le conseil de la
révolution se compose de six membres
sa création avait été décidée alors que
l'ayatollah khomeini se trouvait encore
en france son cerveau jusqu'ici et l
ayatollah motahari assassiné la semaine
dernière on vient de constituer la barre
un corps de gardiens de la révolution
présenté comme force autonome et
indépendante et dont les effectifs sont
gardés secrets il est prêt à être
engagées immédiatement
partout où la sécurité de l'état mexique
touche france depuis onze ans le monde
littéraire française se donner rendez
vous en mai à nice pour un festival du
livre qui accueillait à chaque fois plus
de cent mille visiteurs
c'était un événement or cette année les
25 plus grands éditeurs français leur
stand leurs écrits baba dette n'ont pas
fait le déplacement de nice le festival
s'est transformé en une manifestation
régionale avec le concours d'auteurs
venus de paris comme invitée des
organisateurs
alain gillot-pétré notre reporter se
demande si l'année prochaine
v
à un 12e festival du livre de nice
c'est peu de dire que le festival du
livre de nice dans sa version nationale
n'existe plus nous l'avons rencontrée
plus d'éditeurs plus de médias plus
d'informations stand famélique colloque
éthique prix littéraire symbolique
non décidément fête du livre fête du
livre morne fait il n'empêche les
organisateurs restent optimistes ce
festival solliciter les éditeurs l'an
prochain mon intention est de réunir à
nice les 800 ou 900 vendeurs de livres
importants de france des pays
francophones de l'europe et des deux
amériques et de dire aux éditeurs venez
les voir ou ne venez pas les voir et je
suis persuadé qu'ils viendront les voir
heureusement il ya les écrivains en les
solliciter - du temps que les éditeurs
venait à nice ils sont aujourd'hui à la
première place la juste place avec tout
de même le sentiment d'être un peu en
représentation est un petit peu en effet
on a invité cette année beaucoup
d'auteurs on a l'impression que c'est
parce que justement les éditeurs de
littérature générale c'est à dire les
plus grands éditeurs ne sont pas
présents et il est triste qu'on ne
rencontre jamais au même endroit et les
éditeurs et les auteurs
et cette année si on les a invité les
auteurs en grands noms c'est peut-être
qu'on avait besoin d'une roue de secours
pour sauver les restes du festival de
toute façon sans auteur il peut pas y
avoir de festival du livre
il se trouve que cette année il y a tout
petit peu de d'éclairage sur
les auteurs et je crois que c'est une
excellente chose mais le rôle de vedette
qu'on vous fait jouer et il encore
compatible avec la littérature
vous savez c'est un rôle de vedette
c'est vraiment beaucoup dire un rôle de
starlettes si vous voulez et ça a
toujours été lié à la littérature parce
que la littérature a toujours eu quelque
chose à voir avec le spectacle c'est un
spectacle sur une scène qui n'est pas
distincte de la rue si la littérature y
trouve son compte les écrivains et le
public aussi
foin des querelles littéraire et
éditoriale qui n'intéresse que les
spécialistes que vivent ce genre de
festival à condition qu'ils se déplacent
que le livre soit vraiment le centre et
la lecture le fruit c'est le sentiment
provençal d' yvan audouard
mais le problème vollard 6 juin j'allais
20 ans à venir voir jouer en festival
uimm sig et les bazars clients sont
toujours très gai mais en tout cas on
festival de cannes c'est un festival de
cinéma
ça n'empêche pas qu'il vient de mon film
je me demande si après tout en sueur
festival libre il n'ya pas de partis et
de câblage et les rayons avant les
germes de la mission d'era brutale je
suis là pour le plaisir et je vous jure
que votre président est très grand
surtout quand je sais qui fait 2 degrés
à paris alors ni ce que je voulais même
avec des livres c'est une ville que les
habitants
cela dit le goncourt de la nouvelle a
été décerné à andrée chedid pour les
corps et le temps
paru chez flammarion un prix littéraire
patronné par france culture a récompensé
roger laporte pour trois ouvrages qu'il
vient de publier chez hachette
littératures enfin notre confrère jean
michel royer a pris l'initiative d'un
prix qui sera décerné par l'association
nationale des bibliothécaires de france
laquelle choisira le livre ali court à
longchamp deux épreuves des toutes les
deux sur 2400 mètres
le prix hocquart un classique pour
poulains de 3 ans gagné par le marmot et
le dire c'est un des cas pour les
chevaux plus âgés remporté par et le
condor
voici les images de cette course
commentée par pires
ce qui est agréable avec les courses
classiques comme le prix hocquart c'est
que l'on est rarement déçu les meilleurs
poulains de 3 ans de ce lot ait syrah et
le marmot était connu et leur match très
attendu dès l'ouverture des boîtes high
sierra a pris la tête et la corde menant
bon train tout le peloton malgré le
terrain l'eau dans son sillage le marbre
attend patiemment avant de venir prendre
davantage avec la facilité d'un grand
champion
ce qui m'a choqué club j'espère et
je pensais 1 place ont grimpé à ribot
appuie la façon de galoper comme beau et
tout était aidé par le terrain lourd
mais j'ai toujours cru beaucoup je crois
qu'il est très bon est ce que vous avez
comme un trop grand pour l'un ou pour
une autre écurie cette année poule 1 g
boitron shachtman chez un autre cheval
qui n'a jamais couru cette année encore
il n'a pas couru cette année encore du
très bon c'est à l'arrivée à river et
puis je crois une très bonne police
après ça le pénis
nous regardons maintenant l'arrivée du
tiercé dans le prix de la reine
marguerite effet reviennent le plus
rapide au départ règles allure du
peloton suivi de el condor rose à tort
corsa rios et prince peine à la hauteur
du pavillon rpu vianne toujours calé à
la corde et celui de graviano el condor
en dehors france est et corse are you à
150 mètres du poteau el condor qui a
pris l'avantagé maintenant attaquées par
prince ted et nafie tocci qui sont à la
luce el condor admirablement soutenu par
jean parrat l'emportent devant prince
ted et nachi cheese arrivée 13 6 474 250
et dans le désordre pour 5 francs 776
points 50
voilà mais vraiment je voudrais revenir
aussi sur le prix hocquart parce que
quand un cheval de course devient un
grand champion aussitôt regarde ses
origines alors en hommage à son père qui
fait un grand champion je voudrais
rappeler celle de le maroc est un
produit issu de muyinga et de
l'excellente étalons à marco qui
malheureusement est mort l'année
dernière
et puis je voudrais parler aussi d'une
course importante dans la journée sur
1000 mètres ligne droite c'était le prix
saint georges une course de groupe 3 où
la grande favorite things i a beaucoup
déçu moi j'ai l'impression que c'est le
terrain lourd qui l'a gêné mais j'ai eu
criquette head son entraîneur qui m'a
donné l'explication cette contre
performance elle m'a dit que s'il y
était tellement bonne tellement avait
tellement de classe qu'elle est très
difficile entraîner s'il n'y a pas de
chevaux à l'écurie ainsi rapide pour
travailler avec elle
alors il faut considérer que cette
course de rentrée est excellente et
qu'il faudra plus fort la gg la
prochaine fois lors de sa prochaine
sortie
et bien voilà des informations
précieuses pour le rugby quarts de
finale du championnat de france bannière
a battu nice 14 10 agen battu grouillait
13,9 montferrand toulouse 12 6 et hier
vous le savez narbonne avait battu
bayonne 18 sept
cyclisme le tour d'espagne après 12
étapes c'est toujours le français
christian levasseur qui porte le maillot
jaune football à la suite des résultats
d'hier soir le champion de france est
complètement relancé jusqu'ici et depuis
le début de la saison c'est à dire août
dernier strasbourg dominé monaco
strasbourg s'est fait battre par
marseille alors que saint-etienne a
battu metz et que n'ont pas fait match
nul devant valenciennes
et voilà les trois clubs de tête j'en
pense strasbourg saint-etienne et nantes
groupés en deux petits points seulement
le champion de france est devenue plus
passionnant que jamais nous allons
revoir les instants décisifs des trois
matches qui ont relancé son intérêt avec
marseille strasbourg tout d'abord avec
le but de la défaite du leader de l'ailé
droite le marseillais boubacar va
adresser un centre du robert buigues
reprend de la tête
une reprise qui surprend le gardien
international dominique dropsy
strasbourg et ça ira bien d'égaliser
mais marseille ne laissera rien passer
malgré cette défaite les alsaciens
restent leaders mais à marseille
strasbourg a perdu le match est un
joueur roger jouve
victime d'une fracture de la mâchoire
passons à saint-etienne metz où les
verts vont trouver l'ouverture à la 28e
minute de la première mi temps grâce à
un joli tir croisé de leur attaquant
international dominique rocheteau
ce sera d'ailleurs le seul but de la
rencontre
mais ce but permet à saint-etienne de
revenir à la deuxième place du
classement un point seulement de
strasbourg pour finir valenciennes
nantes avec le premier but pour les
nantais sur ce coup franc tiré par le
jeune milieu de terrain oscar muller
mais valenciennes va répliquer sur
l'action qui suit ou jacques talonnera
pour la rva rond qui égalisera après ce
match nul nantes est troisième à deux
points de strasbourg suite du
championnat et de cette course poursuit
samedi 19 mai
nous terminerons par une belle histoire
c'est presque une légende celle du
tchador elle va nous expliquer comment
est née dans les pays islamiques
le port du voile par les femmes se
voilent dont on a tellement parlé par
exemple pendant les événements d'hier en
7 les jambes mais à samarkand en
ouzbékistan nous est compté pour vous
bah gérard gorisse sa splendeur
samarcande la doit à l'un des
conquérants les plus intrépides est
aussi l'un des plus cruelles de
l'histoire tamerlan qui régna par le feu
et le sang
conquérants boiteux et mal formées de
naissance musulmans il affirmé il n'ya
qu'un dieu dans le ciel il ne doit y
avoir qu'un seul empereur sur la tête
parti de samarcande dont il voulait
faire la capitale du monde avec ses
armes et ouzbeks
il réussit à conquérir toute l'asie
centrale l'inde la turquie l'iran son
empire s'étendait jusqu'à l'egypte
sous mes poupées se termina sous la
muraille de chine
son génie militaire et sa cruauté
n'avait d'égal que son goût pour le
splendide il voulait que samarcande
devienne la plus belle ville de
l'univers tamerlan et ses descendants
ont laissé et trésors d'architecturé
mais cette vie là aussi une
particularité à samarcande aînés l'une
des traditions de l'islam
le port du voile pour les femmes cette
tradition c'est à merlan qu'il aurait
imposé ici même à l'emplacement de cette
mosquée de ce palais en cours de
rénovation
voici ce que dit la légende
binic à nous une très belle chinoise
l'une des épouses de tamerlan le fier
conquérant décida en l'absence de son
mari parti guerroyer et conquérir la
moitié du monde de construire en son
honneur
la plus belle mosquée est aussi le plus
beau palais du royaume c'est ainsi
qu'elle fit venir le meilleur architecte
de lempire les travaux commencèrent mais
biblique à nous était si belle que très
rapidement
l'architecte tomba follement amoureux de
la belle chinoise
l'architecte fille alors du chantage
habitat nous lui disant que si elle
voulait que la construction du palais et
de la mosquée continue il faudrait
qu'elle lui accorde au moins un seul
baiser
bibi cas nous sommes fidèles à tamerlan
son mari ne céda poids mais voici que
l'on annoncé le retour à quelques mois
de la de tamerlan une fois de plus
victorieux alors big and home accepta le
baiser de l'architecte mais ce baiser
fut si fort fut si violent fut si
brûlant dit la légende qu'il laissa sur
le corps de biblique hanoi une marque
indélébile de retour tamerlan fut
émerveillé par le palais par la mosquée
mais il vit aussi la tâche indélébile
biblique hanoi lui raconta toute
l'histoire le conquérant si aussitôt
exécuté l'architecte et il décida
prévenu du danger que la beauté des
femmes faisait courir aux hall que
dorénavant toutes les femmes de son
royaume porteraient le voile
voilà ce que dit la légende
cela se passait au 14e siècle
aujourd'hui nous betis temps toujours
fortement islamisé est sans doute le
seul pays islamisés où plus aucune femme
plus aucune ne porte le voile
en tout cas une belle histoire météo
demain le temps sera brumeux où nuageux
sur la plupart des régions avec des
températures assez basses dans la
journée le ciel restera nuageux sur la
moitié nord où les températures seront
stationnaires tandis que de belles
éclaircies se développeront sur la
moitié sud du pays avec une légère
hausse des maximums vous aurez noté
enfin il n'est plus question dans la
météo depuis voilà
n'oubliez pas ce soir les dernières
informations vous seront donnés par
bernard pavie n'oublions pas non plus
demain antenne de midi et l'édition de
bassin bonne soirée